i see a window behind you and it's a
sliding one so sliding
windows as long as they don't go down
are always openable from the outside
oh hey that's a fun thing to know thank
you for that
that's a really cool thing to know in my
new house
in this new neighborhood uh that there
is a point of entry
for people if they just want to come
inside you should be very worried
cells proliferate and then it creates
disease wait are you doing a bit is that
real
is it real that you can no it's like oh
you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
no no no no you you're you're fine
you're safe
okay is this the new house yeah because
on the show you had made the entire
studio audience on conan yell
um buy me a house
i don't think there's anything people
like more
than someone asking someone who's very
wealthy
to buy them something very expensive and
i think the way the entire audience just
turned on conan
and then just started chanting with me
it's one of the most thrilling moments
of my life i think when you're on tv
people have this idea that you have
millions of dollars if you've ever
appeared on on television before
you are a billionaire and could just
afford a house because we were like well
you could pay for that and i'm like
i made 47
the inflated sense that we have that
anyone on tv is
cash rich though it's fair that conan
could afford to buy you a house in deep
glendale uh
well first of all it's al tadina and i
think you saw
glendale cause i'm armenian yes which
congratulations on the it's not what you
say
when you raise awareness what uh the
is that what that is because i i've i
will
be fine to admit that i was ignorant to
it i thought it was like a reminder of
hey this terrible
genocide happened but there's a new
issue there's an area
in uh there's an area near azerbaijan in
armenia called
artsakh and then the soviet union gave
it to azerbaijan but it's like 95
armenian and they govern it and they've
run it and then azerbaijan just suddenly
brought turkey in
and was like hey turkey come and let's
let's invade this area
and armenians are like what the [ __ ]
and so yeah that's what's happening
right now it's awful
i mean it could become an all-out war
and you know armenians in la were very
vocal very vocal shut down the 101. yeah
so you've probably seen a lot of
armenian flags on a lot of cars
there's a bunch of a bunch of cars on
the 101 and they saw the the orange and
blue flag everywhere
unless past two weeks i've been really
getting it out there but i've just been
not paying attention to the message but
now we know
now you know you've been doing a team
cocoa show so
mustachio fixes your life
where you've talked about hey how you
could scam the uh
pet support system as my pet animal
how do i convince my husband then our
landlord we need a pet you need a pet
look up all the reasons people have
service dogs whether it's like
social anxiety then it becomes like a
medical issue
you've also talked about something
called juice juice says how do you
manage a stressful day at work
something called juice juice time
trouble at work you're stressed
um drink on the job that's juice juice
time
you know am i qualified some would say
maybe i'm not
but i think that i am because i've lived
and so
when these people ask me these questions
that are very serious
i like to re like take from my
experiences
and say when i'm stressed at work i do
things like i
have juice juice time which is you take
a normal looking beverage whatever it is
orange juice
and you put a little bit of vodka in
there
or any other type of alcohol that's
easily accessible
and you put it on your desk in a uh
in a like water bottle or some sort of
hidden vessel
it's a cocktail yes you mix alcohol with
you're telling
a non-alcoholic beverage right you take
something
i don't know we'll call it like you mix
it so let's call it a mixer
it's kind of mixing you take some
alcohol
and you put it in this mixer and then
yeah you know that way you can have a
nice
buzz but you're not getting like you
know
hollywood boulevard wasted at work okay
so it's it flies into the radar i'm
always nervous about that even for like
doing stand-up online like that people
would know i'm drunk for something
has anyone caught on to you in the
office
but been to your desk it's fluorescent
lights there's always episodes of
friends playing
bud shotgun there's anyone been like hey
you seem happy
what's uh wrong happening
first of all i should say i don't do
juice time all the time i think that's
like
that's a problem yeah but i don't know
but when i do
do it my eyes do kind of glaze over
and uh my reaction time slows down
and so i think people are like
do you have a do you have a fun lunch
that's code for that i don't know
it sounds different about you i got
highlights and they're like what
yeah and then they're after the next
thing yeah sona fixes your life i think
that i've
fixed a lot of lives it's amazing what
you can do by just
answering a single question that people
have
could you fix my life right now
i'm supposed to go back out on the road
because um
i'm supposed to shoot this special and
some comedy clubs are open
i know hbo max special hey
clubs are open and i'm a little worried
right now
i think if i fix my life that maybe the
clubs aren't the most sanitary
environments that maybe they're not
taking as seriously as
like a big brand like target because
it's like a comedy club employee
it's like yeah what that down no comedy
clubs are
have always been disgusting yeah i'm
gonna digress for a second
so uh i feel like i've never seen like
an
updated comedy club and so
you have no like okay so once i went
this is really random i went to the
playboy mansion once yeah
and i went there not for a party i went
there for a nice
lunch with two other people and we just
sat
and we had lunch there was no like naked
girls running around or anything
but then i got a tour of the playboy
mansion after and they took us to this
one room
open this door and the floor is like a
soft cushy bed
and it's clear that they were just like
orgies on orgies on orgies in here
and i don't think that they changed
that flooring since like 1976
right because there's no fitted sheet
for a floor
well it's like it's like the carpet it's
just it's weird it was like a
very soft flooring my point is i look at
comedy clubs that same way as i do as
that room that was in the playboy
mansion
yeah and like back in the day people
were like doing it
and they were like doing coke and
whatever
so there's like the entire club is just
full of
jizz and coke remnants
and like drink yeah that people spilled
and people laughing and they're spit all
over the place
and the jizz if you're a good comedian
the whole audience is
[ __ ] so much just everything you see
the comics choosing yeah you are right
that they're not
updated at all in the fact that there'll
still be like photos up of
of cancelled comedians that were
cancelled a long time ago like that guy
was canceled for doing jokes about the
challenger
and that's a lot but i think you'll be
fine
okay here's the thing so your advice for
me is i think you'll be fine
and watch out for jizz puddles yeah
like you've been to protests i've been
to protests
yeah that like i thought that they were
gonna be really scary if you have a mask
and you stay away from people and you
don't touch
any of anything in the comedy club then
i think you're gonna be fine
okay yeah if you're going to catch
anything it's going to be like
syphilis not cold right it's going to be
a hepatitis
it's going to be yeah one of the strange
which we have vaccines for
it's fine please i always say don't let
hepatitis dominate your life yeah
give me hepatitis no don't that was
terrible no
don't no i was trying to say like
oh i i'd rather have something that's
treatable than
what you just included in the in the diy
conan where they reanimated fans of the
show
reanimated your interview when you're on
the show after kumal
canceled yeah so there's animators
submitting there's people playing you
how how did you feel about the betrayal
i loved it for the most part
for the most part it was all very
flattering and sweet
there was one that someone drew
where i look like 400 pounds
is this the one that you had super
powers like you come out
and you i completely evaporate
andy that's not it but now you're making
me think that there's an
oh maybe that is it was a it was a
hand-drawn animation where i'm like
your signature face your headshot yeah
oh my god this person has
no neck you know when they put tin mark
like right here
and then it's just like yeah the space
oof oh is that how people see me but i
you know it's fine but everything else
it was really sweet i
i i mean you know i can't see the
drawings are tough
and i think what happens when people
draw you is they accentuate the one
feature about your face that you
maybe don't like it's the most extreme
in an effort to capture you
yeah and it's flattery but it is the
meanest roast of your life you're like
oh well now i'm worried about
that part what's the feature let's talk
about it the photo of me looked like
it looked like uh if dobby from harry
potter was allowed to become a real boy
it is very troubling it's just like oh
we gave him some
man features like every time they do
those things like like homer simpson
what if he looked like
what would he look like as a real human
he looked like that but with dobby
oh but moses i think that just means
that you're very like
delic you're delicate but i die on a
beach
yeah yeah like not i'm not trying to be
mean but you
are you look like a prince from another
era
that like no one was allowed to touch a
delicate prince
yes that that is what i go what's my
brand a delicate prince and don't touch
me sir this that's somehow worse than
the animation that's worse than the
drawing come on
it's nice you know what's good about it
is if somebody comes up to you and is
like trying to underestimate you like
i mean ken i'm a delicate prince you're
not allowed to touch me
i'm a prince not even a king a prince
means i didn't even earn it i was born
into the status
don't touch my crimson milk skin have
you ever been in a fight
i feel like you're just like a lover not
a fighter yeah i was in a fight
uh maybe i was like 19. have you been in
a fight
never i've been in a lot of verbal
fights but never a physical one
it is insane when you zoom out of a
because like my girlfriend and i are
very close and we're also very loud
together it started like we were making
fun of couples that had like weird names
which are like shaker kiki i'm like
what's the worst nickname
but now we've completely abandoned that
bit so we're actually calling each other
like you're garbage you're pee
and there was just a woman like watering
her plants that
had never hurt us before so terrifying
oh my god i love your girlfriend can you
tell what kind you guys said
she loves you she's always mad in the
corner
over there you just keep her in the
corner while you do this
just tell her like don't move from that
spot got the eye keeper there she takes
up residence in the corner
we'll mark her territory with some pee
and then
always ready to attack so for the
viewers at home just know that my
girlfriend's ready to attack
she's up on the feeling like the movie
hereditary where she's uh
like ready to pounce she wants me to
stop doing this show
she's she creates all these burner
accounts so all the youtube comments
like do you show
socks where's conan it's all her oh my
god
that's the twinkle of fear is in my eyes
so how do i fix that fix my life
um i think you just give her whatever
she wants
soda thank you so much for joining us
that was fun i
love talking to you moses right let's do
this when it's not recorded i'm down
where are you where are you okay are you
in
uh let me give you my exact address on
the air yeah
this this this on
it's really just yeah yeah yeah we're
the only people still here
in in l.a yeah well
world's ending thank you so much for
joining us sonam assassin 50's your life
is the show go to the team coco
instagram you can see it all bye bye
zona say hi to
contour for me come too she won't come
off the ceiling okay
classic all right bye